les fonctions de police sont épuisés
depuis des semaines ils sont rappelés
avec toutes les manifestations qui peut
y avoir en france tous les mécanismes
rappeler avec des heures supplémentaires
qui ne sont pas payés les airs de nuit
ne sont pas revalorisés donc il ya un
épuisement général on court à la
catastrophe
parce que 62 millions de moins sur notre
budget ça implique des recrutements
moins et déjà que nous sommes en
sous-effectif partout en france dans
tous les commissariats de réduire ce
budget de 70 millions
c'est courir notre perte est par exemple
à nevers pour que le commissariat
fonctionne correctement il nous faudra
encore cinq fonctionnaires pour pouvoir
retourner dans une bonne condition
actuellement on est sur le fil du rasoir
on tire sur la corde les fonctionnaires
sont épuisés ils ont des heures
supplémentaires qui ne peuvent pas
récupérer ou très peu qui ne sont pas
payés donc le ras-le-bol est général
en fait cette journée noire elle va
consister à quoi demain parce que c'est
un appel national qu'est ce que ça va
faire la paix nationale
oui alors les commissariats vont assurer
les missions d'urgence uniquement pour
le reste les fonctionnaires ne sortiront
pas le commissariat sera fermé dans tout
l'est comesa de france ça va vraiment
alors tout à fait c'est le mouvement
devrait être très suivie mais ce n'est
que l'acteur
si le gouvernement n'entend pas la
grogne des policiers d'autres mesures
seront prises
de plus importante